hey how's it going bros my name is Peter
power I'm recording this very early in
dawn to be fitting this game just got
released at midnight I'm so pumped to
play it I heard about this game first
almost four years ago and it's one of
those games I didn't actually think
would come out but it did it's been
quiet about it for so long and now it's
here and I'm like yes so excited to play
this so this is a horror game of a heavy
rain style I think and it's based of
horror movie cliches let's just begin
playing I think this will be an amazing
series bros feel free to leave your
support like and comment
yay and I'll try and keep this up every
single day for you I'm so pumped [ __ ]
yes if this game lives up to like half
of my excitement I'll be happy I try not
to get pumped for games oh my god it
just jump scared mean hasn't even
started beautiful tile is green it has
bonus content yes
I've actually excited about DLC man I
lost it cool this is sorry the butterfly
effect so the choices in this game a
tiny button flapping its wings a tiny
butterfly flapping its wings today may
lead to a devastating hurricane the
choices in this game has effect over the
story which is awesome I think those are
the most entertaining games to watch but
all I will play as well yeah there you
go
they're there telling you
and we're taking one path in the
butterfly wing okay well just forget
everything I said the last minute cuz
apparently the game is gonna repeat it
now I'm so sorry
this is really cool your story it's one
of many possible I wonder how many
excuse your actions carefully they
always hint battle it's like so many
different things you can do and then you
actually play in them they like it there
were no difference come on we'll see
this looks cool it starts up like this
okay
like I'm the murderer like I'm about to
stab up some kids don't tell my channe
yeah what are we doing it looks awesome
look at the graphics sorry
there's so many people so we're about to
play a prank on someone
Kanna
what's going on that's Hannah Mike it's
Hannah hey Hannah oh [ __ ]
[Music]
damn rich kids oh my god Josh I like my
hat
wait I'm playing out of this girl out of
all people are you kidding me okay fine
Josh that damn it Josh
what [ __ ] well I have no idea what I'm
supposed to do so I might as well just
explore I'm I go upstairs X Kent that's
a door okay I wanted to go upstairs
though game stop teasing me to press X
cuz I know I'm not gonna fall over that
[ __ ] all right gotta say it looks
gorgeous I didn't expect it to look this
good very impressive
am I supposed to look at the window
maybe
ah here we go tutorial use the right
stick to look around
bad bad bit yep this is how you look
around why is she like okay whatever we
got an empty bottle
press and hold LR 2 to pick up the
bottle god I can inspect the bottle and
see that it's empty
jeez Josh okay she's touching his
brother inappropriately
that's not cool it's not cool man what
do we got at paper which I can inspect
yes Hannah you look so damn hot in that
shirt I said that except I like the
shirt all right it's a good shirt but I
bet you're even hotter out of it Oh Mike
come to the guest room at 2:00 a.m. Mike
xxx so there you go press if you ever
want to be with the girl named Hannah
just compliment her shirt oh my god oh
[ __ ] we're not Hannah oh [ __ ] oh my god
she fell for it ha ha ha take the shirt
off
she's like but I really wanted to take
off my shirt guys you ruined it how was
that a panic guy has a selfie stick
that's like the definition of a jerk all
right use the right stick to choose
choose one fine oh [ __ ]
for [ __ ] sake Eddie I made a choice
bad even knowing it okay I think we made
the right move
press the correct action button before
oh my god QuickTime events yeah what
else you got fast or safe fast gotta go
fast in my yoga pants yeah
damn look at that [ __ ] how did I know
she went here anyway well I guess those
are her tracks
now what follow the footprints or follow
noise and follow the footprints yep that
makes sense
my god Hannah became a moose three mice
yeah we made the wrong choice
right damn it Hannah where are you
I really like the interaction supply it
feels like I'm playing a horror movie
which I'm guessing is the point now
we're gonna take a selfie because
obviously okay slide enough okay hahaha
that's cool you can direct the light be
using the right step okay that's cool
I'm controlling this very nice beautiful
look at this gorgeous
Hannah panic okay I'm taking us I want
to take a selfie can you hold to walk
faster
walk faster come on let me sprint damn
it
what is this this is Hannah's favorite
toy know what a death totin what does
that mean no big deal we'll just be
going on my way now
death totin doesn't sound so bad I have
a bad feeling about that you know
they're like her history is about to end
if your name is bath then I'm sorry
oh god what that means do not go there
if someone has to flamethrower you
usually don't approach them what the
heck we actually found her and shooting
them taking the shirt off Hannah
oh my god yes [ __ ] predator vision
those yoga pants and really liked them
in this thing oh [ __ ]
what is going on no my phone what are we
running from
uh-oh oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god nice angle
that's some nice yoga pants' angling
right there thank you developers oh my
god who wants a high fire
what's a help oh [ __ ] he wants to help
ah I'm sorry Hannah
this is fresh no oh [ __ ] me I [ __ ] that
thin that oh my god we both die Jesus
Christ oh my god
all right now I know already what your
brothers are thinking oh you should have
let go you should have kept Hannah they
both died anyway all right calm down
[Music]
oh my god it's that actor you see no one
could change what happened last year the
past is beyond our control see he said
it except this in order to move forward
but there is freedom in this revelation
everything you do every decision you
make from now on will open doors to the
future I want you to remember this I
want you to remember this as you play
your game wait don't talk to me like
that will affect you fate and the fate
of those around you
that's too close so you have committed
to commands with this game this is
significant and I want to help you see
it through sometimes sometimes these
things can be a little scary even
terrifying but I'm here to make sure
that no matter how upsetting things may
get you will always find a way to work
through it
oh you can't all right we will start
with a simple exercise could you please
pick up a card and I want you to look at
the picture on the other side and tell
me what you feel about it
what yeah this is so weird answer
honestly in order to get the most out of
this experience I have to answer
honestly okay I'm looking down and I'm
grabbing the paper and I'm looking at
okay it's farm now what so how did that
picture make you feel this reminds me of
Silent Hill shattered Memories where
they would do like a psycho analysis on
you and then base the scares of the game
on how you answered it makes me feel
uneasy okay yeah I was honest all right
so you came
the Scarecrow Jesus Christ is the first
thing I saw yep let's see we're not
there would you feel comfortable staying
there on your own for a period of time
let's say a week for example a week no
[ __ ] now oh no I don't like this because
it looks creepy it's a yacht it boring
I'm not gonna sleep in a barn for a week
I'm sorry is there something else in
that picture that I'm seeming like a
such a [ __ ] now no time for now I don't
like this I would like you to
contemplate what it is that it's missing
from that picture the Sun a thing that's
driving your fear we need to unwrap it
don't you agree but the next time
what is going on I don't trust him
I don't trust him
I don't here we go that was the intro I
know this is gonna be an amazing series
I feel like this is the game I waited
for for such a long time and I and I
can't wait to play it with together with
you bros so I'm gonna do one a day but
please do keep leaving your support and
share their share or whatever and yeah I
can't wait for the next one I'll see you
stay awesome breasts